Hi, ang pangalan ko ay Katy Beslado.
Ako ang director ng IBM Quantum strategy
at applications research. Narito ako para pawiin
ang pinakamaraming mito tungkol sa quantum computing
hangga't kaya ko sa loob ng animnapung segundo.
Isa sa mga magagandang bagay: totoo ito.
At mayroon kaming mga device sa IBM Cloud na maaaring ma-access ng sinuman.
Oo, pero para lang sa ilang bagay na talagang magaling silang gawin—
ang napakakumplikadong matematika na ginagamit ng sansinukob,
pero kung gusto mong gumawa ng spreadsheet o mag-email, gamitin
ang iyong PC.
Oo, sa teorya, pero hindi pa
sa malapit na hinaharap. Wala pang computer na sapat na magaling para gawin iyon
sa ngayon. Para sa nakikitang hinaharap, nasa tamang landas tayo,
at kapag nakarating na tayo roon, babaguhin natin ang paraan ng pagpoprotekta
ng impormasyon.
Ganap na mali iyon. Ang mga quantum computer
ay kaibang-kaiba sa pundamental
at gumagamit ng mga batas ng kalikasan para iproseso ang impormasyon.
Ang AI ngayon ay tumatakbo sa klasikong mga device,
pero naniniwala kami na magtutulungan sila sa hinaharap.
Hindi totoo iyon. Mayroon kaming isang napakalaking ecosystem
ng mga startup, academia, national lab, at mga partner sa industriya na
gumagamit ng aming mga device araw-araw.
Hindi. Ang "quantum-inspired" ay matagal na nang umiiral
at tumatakbo sa mga klasikong device. Hindi nito
maibibigay ang tunay na pangako ng quantum computing.
Kung gusto mo ng tunay na quantum computing, kailangan mong gawin ito sa tunay na quantum
computer.